[Music]
foreign
explosion and there's a there are
there's a picture for suggesting the
same right now explosion
[Music]
you can just type a sentence into a one
of these text to image generators which
are AI based and it'll turn out an image
how does this play into some of the
existing problems we have with you know
the ways people deceptively
miscontextualize an image to claim it's
one thing when it's another right they
show you know an act of violence against
one ethnic group and claim it's against
another and try and incite violence so
this is basically a supercharger of
those existing tendencies
[Laughter]
I think the problem is and this is why
we worry about this when we look at AI
generated images as these tools are
getting better and better yes for the
moment this was an easy one right you
could easily look at a live feed and see
that the Pentagon wasn't burning and if
you look at other contexts right places
that don't have live feeds places that
don't have the attention of fact
Checkers places that don't have other
Witnesses places where maybe the AI has
got better that's what we need to worry
about as we go forward